Simplify the rational
expression and state the domain.
So we have a rational
expression here.
One expression being
divided by another one.
And so to simplify
it, I am guessing
that we will have to
factor this top expression
and this bottom expression.
And there's probably
common factors
that we might be
able to cancel out.
But we have to be very
careful about how we do them.
So let's factor each of these.
So you may or may
not remember how
to factor quadratic
expressions that
have a non-one
coefficient out here.
So this will be
practice in that.
And we go into the rationale
for why it works in those videos
where we first learned to
factor rational expressions.
And they're in this playlist.
But just as a reminder,
what you want to do is you
want to split this middle term.
You want to split the first
degree term into two terms.
You want to group it, one
of them with this 2x squared
and one of it with the 20.
And you want to group
it into two terms
so that the coefficients
of the two terms,
when you take their product, is
the same thing as 2 times 20.
So you want to break--
let me write it over here.
You want to break 13x,
you want to break it
into an ax plus a bx, where a
times b is equal to 2 times 20.
And we show why this
works in a previous video.
So a times b needs
to be equal to 40.
And a plus b needs
to be equal to 13.
So let's just think
about the factors of 40.
1 and 40 are not going to work.
2 and 20 are not going to
work, they don't add up to 13.
3 and 3-- well, 3
doesn't go into 40.
4 and 10 does not work.
5 and 8-- so if we take 5
times 8, that does equal 40.
And then 5 plus 8 does equal 13.
So that's looking pretty good.
So let's split up the
13x along those lines.
So we get 2x squared plus 5
plus 5x plus 8x is plus 20.
So all I did is I split up
this 13x into a 5x plus an 8x.
And now we can group
these two terms.
And then let's go down over
here and do the same thing
in the denominator.
So let's do the same exact
thing in the denominator.
Once again, we want to find
two numbers that add up to 17
and whose product is
2 times 30, or 60.
So if we look at the factors
of 60, 1 and 60 don't work.
They don't add up to 17.
Or if you took the negative
1 and negative 60--
you're not going to have
negative numbers because they
would have to be the same
sign since this is positive.
And then they would give you
a negative value over here.
So we have to deal
with positive numbers.
2 and 30 don't work.
3 and 15-- remember, we
want to get to 2 times 30,
we want to get to 60.
3 times 15-- sorry,
not 3 times 15.
3 times 20 doesn't work.
Their product is 60, but
it doesn't add up to 17.
4 times 15 does not work.
5 times 12-- 5 times 12
is 60, so that works.
That's the same
thing as 2 times 30.
It equals 60.
And 5 plus 12 is 17.
So that's looking pretty good.
So let's separate
this out into 2x
squared plus 5x
plus 12x plus 30.
And then we can
group them like this.
And then let's see
how we can simplify
each of these expressions.
This top expression over here,
we have a common factor of x.
So this top
expression over here,
we can factor out
an x out of this.
So this becomes x times-- and
2x squared divided by x is 2x.
5x divided by x, when you
have the x factored out, that
is just 5.
So this first term
is x times 2x plus 5.
And then plus-- over here
we can factor out a 4.
4 is divisible into
both 8x and into 20.
So let's factor out a 4.
So this is 4 times-- 8x with a
4 factored out is now just 2x.
And then 20 with a 4
factored out is just a 5.
And then let's do
the bottom over here.
I'm kind of doing them both
simultaneously in parallel.
The bottom over here,
we can factor out
an x out of this expression.
So this is x times--
once again, 2x plus 5.
Plus, this expression over
here, we can factor out a 6
out of both 12x and 30.
So let's factor out a 6.
And then 12x divided by 6 is 2x.
And then 30 divided by 6 is 5.
2x plus 5.
And so we can simplify this.
We can factor out,
from this term
we can factor out a 2x
plus 5, from this term we
can factor out a 2x plus 5.
So if we factor out a 2x
plus 5 from both of these--
so we're factoring
out a 2x plus 5,
you're left with
an x and a plus 4.
You're left with an x plus 4.
And then down here we can
factor out a 2x plus 5.
Down here we can
factor out a 2x--
let me make it in
that same color.
We can factor out a 2x plus 5.
So we're literally just
factoring out a 2x plus 5,
and we're left with an x plus 6.
We're just doing the
distributive property
in reverse over here. x plus 6.
Now, you might be
tempted to say,
hey look, I have a 2x plus
5 in the numerator, 2x
plus 5 in the denominator,
let me just cancel them out
really fast and I would have
simplified the expression.
We have to be very
careful, because we first
need to think about the domain.
Because if we just
simplify this expression,
and we include things in
the simplified domain that
weren't included in the
original function's domain,
we've actually changed
the expression.
Or we've changed the function.
So we have to be very careful
that even when we simplify it,
we keep the domain the same.
So what's the domain
of this thing?
Well, it's going to be all real
numbers except the ones that
make the denominator equal to 0.
And what are the
numbers that make
the denominator equal to 0?
Well, the denominator is equal
to 0 if x plus 6 is equal to 0,
or 2x plus 5 is equal to 0.
And if x plus 6 is 0, then that
means that x is negative 6.
Subtract 6 from both sides.
Over here we could
subtract 5 from both sides.
So you get 2x is
equal to negative 5.
Divide both sides by 2, you
get x is equal to negative 5/2.
So the domain of
this expression right
over here, the domain of this
expression-- if we could call
this a function,
if we defined it
as f of x is equal to all
of this-- the domain of it
is going to be all real
numbers, except negative 6
and negative 5/2.
These will make this
expression undefined.
It will make this
denominator equal to 0.
Now we can simplify it, as long
as we keep this denominator.
So now, if we assume
that we're never
going to see a negative
5/2, then 2x plus 5
is never going to be
equal to 0, and so we
can divide the numerator and
denominator by that value,
canceling it out.
And so the simplified
expression is what's left over.
x plus 4 over x plus 6.
But we have to keep
the same domain.
If we didn't write
this here, you'd
say, OK, the only
thing that would
make this thing 0 is x
is equal to negative 6.
We have to remember, this is
a simplified version of that.
And in order for these to be
identical expressions, or maybe
identical function
definitions, they
need to have the
exact same domain.
So the domain for this
simplified expression
has to be the same
as the original.
All real numbers except
negative 6 and negative 5/2.